so yeah i mean like we haven't gone to
the event now but by the time that uh
this episode comes out we would have
already been to anime expo uh and uh
having to deal with them
in terms of explaining the fact that we
need security is just didn't go through
at all so they
uh we asked for security after our
incident at mcm and after our experience
at mcm and uh they kind of just refused
to
give us any i mean mind you we're guests
yeah at this
security at the con so why would you
need
yeah why would you need any additional
ones but we won't have anyone like with
us yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah
and that's all we said and you know we
we even said like hey we had this
incident at mcm where unfortunately
security was not present we don't want
the same thing happening at amex but
because or future cons in general right
yeah and they were like sounds like your
problem bro yeah so we just pay for it
so we have to pay for our own security
yeah but it's like because
if if the com was like hey we gave you
like a [ __ ] ton of money you can you
know for coming then it'd be like okay
well all right but animation doesn't pay
guests yeah i uh i was talking to um
when we were we went to gamescom in
germany
yeah that was [ __ ] awesome but we
were we were with blizzard and blizzard
gave us these two
gigantic lads to take care of us and
they were oh my god i'm still friends
with them on instagram like oh my god
these these guys were so awesome i
wonder if it's like a if it's like a if
it's a disconnect with the whole like
hollywood thing in america right maybe
and then like because when we were in
speak your mind i heard it no i i'm i'm
going i'm just yeah i i was thinking
maybe but that still wouldn't be an
excuse that's true yeah you're right i
do think it's still just that disgusting
it's like also and i think
there is this weird kind of sense of if
we admit that you're you will bring in
these crowds and we kind of say hey
you're worth that much it means that
they have to then pay you more yeah they
have to offer you more things yeah and
so there is that kind of i at least i
get the sense of like we don't want to
be like wow you're such a big deal or
something like that
because we don't want to have to then
step of what we have to do yeah
i think so i'm sure you maybe think that
way when you
kind of feel the interactions you've had
yes were you trying to explain things
and they'll be like yeah but we think we
we know what's going on there's also
that like whole like um like exposure
types i don't want to say like
paid by exposure this is nonsense
because like
ultimately the algorithm at like tick
tock at twitter and youtube is could get
you so so so much more exposure than any
amount of people you could meet at a
convention you might make stronger
connections and you might make more
worthwhile yeah viewers yes but in terms
of like growth and actually like is it
worth like five days or six days right
not really like after a certain point
it's not worth it i do wonder too
because like there are some things that
i've done in my like career that i was
like i'm just gonna do it i don't care
if you pay me or not because it gets
your foot in the door no definitely and
so then it kind of gets you to that
point where you're just like i'm i'm i'm
down like they're like oh get jess she's
down to do it kind of thing but i'm sure
i'm sure that worked because that was
like very early in that kind of 100 yeah
like now it's just like you know it's
it's that's the old school method of
doing things
i mean it's literally you know there's a
big issue with artists getting paid in
just exposure right yeah
um and you know there is like some
benefits to it early on in your career
but like when you're established you
know you've got you got it there's a
part of professionalism that you've got
to like expect from it right yeah yeah
exactly yeah yeah so it's i wonder if a
lot of conventions are operating in that
like oh you're just a youtuber come on
you'll do it there's something sure
there are some not not everyone but
it depends right on who's running it as
well there's a lot a lot of the cons
more often than not they're like i
really like this person or i'm a big fan
i want to get them yeah and if it's you
that's great yeah but if they're a fan
of older media and stuff and they don't
give a [ __ ] about youtube it's it is
like pulling teeth yeah there is a
blatant bias definitely oh yeah yeah
it's understandable i'm like if it's
your con i guess i get it like yeah you
don't want [ __ ] me there that's
totally fine like yeah i'm not like
you know i'll live i'll live well that's
why we're going on tour right yeah oh
yeah
can we talk about that i mean it should
have been already announced
yeah it should be announced by the time
okay this comes out but uh yeah let's do
it ourselves yeah we'll just work yeah
do it ourselves yeah we just like we
just got to the point we're just like
okay yeah cons are cool you know we've
been doing it for a while but now it's
like it's like the new meta i guess to
do something yourself to do something
ourselves right like it's like it's just
become commonplace now for youtubers to
do tours um the otk game thing did you
guys see that
it was like otk's like e3 types
that was awesome yeah yeah yeah i love
that like like our our generation our
group of like creators and stuff like
that are just going like we're just
gonna make our own [ __ ] yeah yeah which
is like so amazing like you're taking
the power from away from like the old
media stuff you're just putting in your
own i mean i mean i think it has gotten
to a point where you do have enough
influence in reach to be able to and
you've as an influencer you get used to
big companies treating you like [ __ ]
because you are an influencer
you know
they kind of like they kind of look down
on you compared to like old traditional
media but then in reality a lot of
people a lot of big mainstream content
creators have the power and reach to
make their own [ __ ] like events and
be even bigger than the the ones that
are run by big official companies
and yeah i mean i don't know how much
it's going to take for like companies to
realize that hey
people watch creators people follow
influencers you know it's and people
want to go see creators irl yeah not
just online exactly would you guys do
the creator clash
uh i wouldn't personally because i don't
i
and we did like some little it's like a
little um like a boxing training thing
where you just have to tap the other
person's shoulder
shoulder and then like dodge and i did
like this little dodgy thing and she was
like what the [ __ ] like what the [ __ ]
was that because you're jittery yeah
[Laughter]
yeah
yeah
yeah
i mean i feel like it would just be like
a good [ __ ] opportunity and it's just
an excuse to stay fit as well right yeah
you get paid to get in in insane shape
yeah like the best shape of your life
that sounds awesome
a real muscly mommy oh my god
that's when the pyramid head cosplays
with abs
wow
monsters in general